it's great to welcome to the program
today dr ashish jah who is a physician
brown university professor and a
world-renowned expert on pandemic
preparedness and response
uh it's so great to have you on i have
so many questions and and we'll just
jump right in
first things first um lots of folks
who were very confident in following cdc
guidelines for 95
of this pandemic um were taking a little
bit of back
at what seemed like a very rapid uh
advancement from the cdc in terms of
mask wearing and what's safe
particularly for vaccinated people
what what's your general sense of the
balance that the cdc struck between what
makes sense medically and also trying to
do things to encourage more people to
want to get
vaccinated yeah so first of all david
thanks for having me here i'm excited to
be on
and you know the cdc has a couple of
different jobs right on one hand
they want to explain to people what the
science is they want to explain to
people what the evidence is
so you don't have to go read all the
scientific papers yourself you can if
you want but you don't have to the cdc
will give you that summary
and then they also have a job of giving
advice to policymakers about how to
manage that science
and what the cdc did was they came out
and said look the science is pretty
clear
if you've been fully vaccinated you're
good to go you do not need to be wearing
a mask in most instances
and you're really you're fine the
problem
is that implementing that policy is hard
for governors because
they don't know who's vaccinated and
who's not and i think there was
maybe a little more attention could have
been paid to thinking through well how
is this going to get implemented
but you know the people who defend the
cdc's decision basically say
mask mandates were kind of on their way
out anyway a lot of states had already
lifted them
and so what the cdc was really doing was
just explaining to people what they
already knew which was that
all the masks wearing all the mask
mandates they're kind of on their way
out
the one thing that i hear from lots of
parents which
that they just don't seem to have an
answer for it and i don't either is
the numbers are going down we're seeing
lower numbers
in many states almost down to
statistical baseline of risk for being
out in the world etc
but nobody under 12 has been vaccinated
and so
how does this all compute and how are we
to to think about that part
yeah no it's a really good question i
have a
you know so i have three kids two of
them are above the age of 12 they're
14 and 16 and one of them is nine who
obviously has not gotten vaccinated so i
think about this a lot from my own
family
and here is how i would think about this
and this is what i've recommended to
people first if you want to protect kids
under 12
the single best thing you can do is make
sure everybody around them is vaccinated
their parents their
older siblings that becomes critical
right that sort of
creates a ring of protection against
those kids second you want to live in a
community with relatively high
vaccination rates
and what that will do is make sure
infection numbers are really low
and then for some high risk things maybe
you want to pay a little extra attention
so
when i think about it you know we have
not done indoor dining with my
nine-year-old
we probably could infection numbers
where i live are really really low
but i've done indoor dining by myself uh
because i'm fully vaccinated
and so what i have recommended is watch
the infection numbers as they get lower
and lower you can do more and more
indoors without mass for kids
but maybe for some indoor things it's
reasonable to still
have the kids mask up if you're going to
be in a crowded indoor space let's say
you're in a community where not
everybody or not a lot of people are
vaccinated
that's where you want to be careful but
other than that right now i think we're
pretty
in pretty good shape even for younger
kids who have not gotten vaccinated
should there be special guidelines for
folks who
have been vaccinated but have either
some particular medical condition or
are immunocompromised or and and if so
for now
at what point can that be eased off of
yeah it's a very good question you know
so what's interesting about this and i
get asked about this a lot from patients
and i
talk about this a lot with my colleagues
immunocompromises a broad
group of people who have some amount of
immunodeficiency
some of those people their vaccine works
just great
uh they're essentially it works as well
as it does for anybody else
some of those other people the vaccine
barely works at all
and so first and foremost you gotta have
a talk with your doctor about the kind
of immune compromised state you have
because it really does vary a lot second
for the people who are
unfortunately in that small group for
whom the vaccine essentially doesn't
work at all
there's studies going on of maybe a
third or a fourth dose of the vaccine
could get them more protection
but unfortunately they need to act like
they're unvaccinated because they are or
their
immune system is acting that way and so
they need to continue to mask up
and if you're if you live with someone
with one of those more severe forms of
immunocompromising you have to be very
careful
certainly everybody around them should
be fully vaccinated
one of the reasons why we've got to get
to very very high levels of vaccination
is there a small proportion of people in
our country who are vulnerable for whom
vaccines won't work
we've got to do a better job protecting
them when we
talk about some of the variants
including the delta variant
maybe first to make sure i'm
understanding the math correctly if
if we read for example that a particular
variant is 60
more transmissible would it be correct
to understand that that means that
given a particular scenario call it
eight minutes
indoors unvaccinated right if normally
there would be
a one percent transmission risk for it
to be 60
more transmissible does that mean that
that becomes a 1.6
transmission risk yeah exactly
exactly that it's 60 relative so you
don't go from 1 to 61 thank goodness
of course uh but right if you let's say
you were at 10 now you're at 16
uh it's that it's at 60 relative risk
but
may not sound like a lot but it actually
when you apply it across
the whole population it's massive and
you can
see it in a place like the united
kingdom which by the way has higher
vaccination rates than we do
still i mean but we're about the same
but they're a little higher
you know they have seen because of the
delta variant and the contagiousness
they have seen a three to four-fold
increase in total number of infections
across the country
despite high vaccinations because this
ver this virus this variant
is so much more contagious so for the
average person who's vaccinated
would learning about the increasing
prevalence of that variant
change what one considers to be safe
like what what i mean is
if you're vaccinated and you see the
case numbers and you're saying
i'm gonna do a trip in two weeks we now
learn about the fact that this variant
is out there
should the average person change their
activity as a result of that
if you're fully vaccinated no if you're
fully vaccinated the good news is
that the vaccines we have hold up very
very well against the delta variant
so if you're let's say you're planning a
trip with four of your friends and
they're all fully vaccinated
do your trip don't worry about the delta
variant the delta variant
you know it poses a marginal problem for
people who are fully vaccinated not much
of one
you just tend to get a little bit more
breakthrough infections but not people
don't get sick because they're fully
vaccinated
delta variant is a huge problem for
people who are not vaccinated
those people are at super much much
higher risk without you know with the
delta variant than without
but if you're fully vaccinated i
wouldn't worry can you talk a little bit
about
particularly in the last three weeks the
hypotheses and discussions about the
origins of this
virus have gone i i don't want to say
that it's gone mainstream
but there's been significantly more
discussion including in places where we
were not
originally seeing it my understanding of
the spectrum
of what is possible would be on the one
hand this had nothing to do with any lab
even as a pit stop
all the way to this was designed as a
bio weapon and deliberately
released i think it's important no
matter what we explore
to not claim something to be likely
until we
have reason to believe that it's likely
but what do you make of the change in
that discussion over the last few weeks
and sort of the state of that question
yeah so let's talk about the science and
where we are first on the signs and then
i will talk about the discussion
yeah so you actually really laid out the
spectrum
well i could have just been a standard
animal to human
species jump very common it's how we
get ebola it's how we got zika this is
pretty much the most common way
that we get novel infections all the way
to it was a bio weapon designed
uh to cause a global epidemic um
you know but that so basically the way i
look at it bioweapon design
incredibly unlikely um a bit more likely
is it was it was in a lab now it could
have been a naturally occurring virus
people were studying in the lab and
there was an accidental leak
that is more likely or it wasn't
deliberately designed as a bio weapon
but they were working on gain of
function
and they caused a virus to become more
lethal and then it leaked
you know a little bit less likely but
still on the possibility range
most likely just based on kind of
experience historical that
there was an animal to human jump though
there's a species of animals probably
bats maybe there's a different uh
intermediary
and and humans got infected the reason i
say that's most likely because again
that's how it usually happens
but here's the bottom line i don't know
the answer
and i would argue that probably no one
else does either i mean if it was a lab
leak maybe a small number of people do
but i certainly don't no one else in the
united states does so what do we need to
do and first of all why is it important
it is important we want to know where
this virus came from we want to
understand it
not just because it helps us manage this
one but prevent future ones
but the other part is we have got to
stop politicizing this like
my god at this point we have managed to
take this thing that's a very
complicated
and important scientific question and
people are talking about it as though
like if you're a democrat you believe
one thing in a republican you believe
another
i just don't know the right answer we
need to investigate it we need to push
china to give us
more cooperation we need to have the us
intelligence and other
intelligence agencies investigated we
really do need to get to the bottom
bottom of this again if i were a betting
person i'd say
probably came from an animal but we're
not we're not making bets here we should
actually sort it out
is it um uh the is it concerning
or is it in any way relevant or
something we should be thinking about
that it's not clear who the first human
to be infected was or is that just
not particularly surprising if indeed
the first human or humans were in a
country of 1.3 billion people
yeah i think it's important to try to
figure out how far back
does this go so there's some recent data
now that's coming out
that suggests that the first cases in
the united states may have been in late
december
and in people who were not traveling
that means that they got it they were
infected by somebody who had traveled
here
maybe in early december starts pushing
the timeline back
you know we probably won't find what
people talk about as kind of patient
zero the first person infected
yeah i doubt we'll find that we might
but i doubt it
but understanding when the virus got
going when were the first group of
people infected
who were the first group were they
people in a lab were they people working
who shopped at that market i think that
will be important part of the tracing
here this has been such a
horrible pandemic we have got to get to
the best of our ability
to the origin not just where it came
from but who are the first people
infected
last thing i wanted to ask about
certainly you like many of us have been
seeing that there
is a very significant correlation right
now between political views and
and vaccination rates um red and blue
states and also within those states
individuals who identify politically one
way versus the other
are these rates now or could they be
different enough
that the future of this virus becomes
essentially it a partisan virus where
there is one political group that is
disproportionately dying from this in
the united states
he has a good question so i actually see
it a little bit differently and let me
kind of make the case for why
okay when i look at the data i mean
there's no doubt about it that if you
just look red states versus blue states
it looks like blue states are doing
great
on vaccinations red states are not but
there's other things about red states
versus blue states so for instance
uh public health infrastructure public
health infrastructure is much better in
a lot of these quote unquote blue states
and that's what's allowing vaccines to
get out to people i still find in a lot
of
quote unquote red states there are a lot
of people who want to be vaccinated
but they're far away from vaccine sites
it's not easy for them to get time off
there are enough barriers that it's
still preventing people so i hope that
the partisan divide
gets better i and part of it is i can
look at states like south dakota which
is a very red state
and 60 to 63 of adults have gotten
vaccinated
almost at the same level as the national
number and i think oh yeah like there
are plenty of people
on both sides of political aisle who
have gotten vaccinated
um i don't i think if this were to
become a partisan virus i think if it
were to become something
that infected one political group more
than i think that'd be very bad for our
country
it would really sap our desire to have
kind of a unified response
uh it would make this just a bad thing
the virus certainly doesn't care about
the politics we've got to do everything
we can
to de-politicize the virus uh not look
at it as a red versus blue thing but as
a human versus virus thing
and everybody get on the team human and
figure out how to defeat the virus
without uh with with without question
yeah we've been speaking with dr ashish
jah who is a physician and brown
university professor
i so appreciate your time today hey it
was my pleasure thanks for having me on